so we wondered what John Paul mcisaac
thinks of this he's the author of
American Injustice he joins us now with
his lawyer Brian De La Roca uh thanks to
both very much for coming on uh
John Paul MC Isaac just to you first in
the obvious question so here you really
are the little guy in this case you're
literally a small business owner and
you're being threatened by the family
that runs the country
are you intimidated by this you must be
a little bit
I'm a little bit but you got to remember
Tucker I've been dealing with
intimidation from old fronts for the
last couple years so I've kind of gotten
used to it this is uh this isn't as bad
as being accused of being a traitor and
working with Russia to affect an
election but it's pretty close
so I would assume as a small business
owner when someone drops a device off
for you to repair you want them to pick
it up so you can get paid
I mean I I assume you didn't want to
take possession of these devices correct
oh absolutely I mean I'm in the business
to recover data or repair and fix these
products and I want to get paid for
these jobs and uh and I didn't
yeah but that's your fault now
apparently it is
um I want to ask your attorney a
question as an attorney and so Hunter
Biden is hired among many others a man
called Abby Lowell who's a long-time
Democratic lawyer well-regarded among
lawyers extremely expensive probably one
of the most expensive attorneys in the
United States do you have any idea how
Hunter Biden who doesn't have a job that
we know of who's all kinds of claims
against him baby mama among others how
is he affording Abby Lowell
well that's the question that I have as
well
um you know Way Beyond that how many
attorneys does he need he's got Abby
Lowell he's got attorneys representing
him in
quite a few of his criminal matters
um how many does he need and the fact
that Abby Lowell actually went along
with this letter
which really produced a lot of lies
about John Paul
saying that John Paul accessed the
information without Hunter's consent
when we have shown Hunter's consent
everyone knows Hunter consented the fact
that this attorney would participate in
this is I just don't understand it well
I mean clearly this is not about Hunter
Biden obviously I'm guessing here I have
no knowledge that I'm not disclosing but
if uh lifelong crackhead who's fighting
you know a million different battles on
a million different fronts and doesn't
appear to have a job can afford Abby
Lowell on a stable of other attorneys
this is clearly an effort by the
Democratic establishment by donors to
crush you guys for political reasons is
that an unfair assumption
well that's exactly that was the first
thing I thought of I received no
notification of these letters until
someone from CBS contacted me yesterday
I was in the car and they asked for a
comment and I had no idea what they were
talking about when I when I read the
letters I I was appalled I I this is
really someone with so much money or
acting like they have a lot of money
going after someone who is really the
little guy and and he's doing it on
purpose he's trying to intimidate and
it's interesting to me that this
happened when it did because
as you may know we filed a lawsuit
against numerous parties CNN Politico
but one of the parties is Hunter Biden
it was very difficult to find where he
was uh he you know he was in DC for a
couple weeks and he was moving around
well we finally tracked them down and we
were able to serve him last week and
now all of a sudden we see this when
there were always there was always talk
of uh oh Hunters going on the offensive
he's going after uh Rudy he's going
after all right never a mention of John
Paul and then all of a sudden two of the
letters of the primary most of the
paragraphs most of the description in
the letters are John Paul
right well right always pick the poorest
guy to destroy Uday and kuse drive into
you drunk and you're the one who gets
punished for it
um you know God speak to you both I
appreciate it John Paul mcasick and
Brian dillaroka thank you both
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight